vending machines are a common sight and
offices airports and elsewhere but
what's inside one Chicago company's
machines is anything but common instead
of chips and candy they're stocked with
fresh and healthy dishes with a gourmet
touch and the company says they're not
going to stop until there's a fresh food
vending machine near you fresh whole
ingredients those are the building
blocks of farmers fridge the company
Luke Saunders founded seven years ago so
here we are in the produce cooler it
looks like you know one of those big
warehouses we shop for groceries
yeah this is the ingredients that you
would see in your home and you'll now
see it in this smart fridge that
frustrated with the lack of quick
healthy choices
Saunders created this easy-to-use
machine that delivers chef curated meals
at the push of a button it's a vending
machine with fresh food isn't that an
oxymoron I think it used to be an
oxymoron
I think thanks to farmers fridge it no
longer is those meals come in ready to
use recyclable jars and include a
variety of salad sandwiches desserts and
snacks like chips and guacamole the food
is only one part of the equation it all
began with this prototype a
stripped-down then souped-up version of
the old-fashioned machine not an easy
task to convert considering all of its
moving parts because the whole idea was
you can take this ugly old vending
machine and if you really think about
the customer experience you can make it
feel like something more and so the
whole idea was how do we make people
feel like this is a restaurant
experience one way is with partnerships
like the one for bread with James Beard
award-winning Baker Greg Wade how does
the Machine work the fridge actually
just keeps track of temperature the
inventory and the way that works is
every single day we know the inventory
in the fridge and so all that food that
we made we can actually allocate most
efficiently across the network every
night isn't there a little
brain inside the machine that says ah
this salads been in too long yeah that's
a huge part of what makes this possible
so if you were to find a fridge on a
Sunday night we hadn't been there yet it
actually wouldn't let you buy some of
the products because their past their
prime what yeah it wouldn't let you buy
it yes we actually say you cannot we're
not letting you buy this so it's
actually be safe to eat but from a
quality perspective we actually shut it
off the quality and recipes that appeal
to a wide variety of tastes is the job
of Emily's Stucker
historically it's been really hard to
make healthy food taste good why is that
is it our palates because they've been
so fried from processed and fast food
yeah traditionally when you think of a
salad you're kind of like okay it's
lettuce it's some raw vegetables but
there isn't a lot of flavor right and so
that's one of the things that we're
striving to do is to create healthy
recipes but that people actually want to
eat so here's some thyme recipes like
this harvest salad these meals are not
only flavorful they're seasonal perfect
and that's your harvest salad what is
your optimal space it's an office
building it's a hospital it's University
it's an airport it's a community center
anywhere where people don't have access
to fresh healthy meals when they want
them at a price they can afford and now
during the Kovach 19 pandemic farmers
fridge is bringing their fresh food to
people's homes there are 100 full-time
employees that work here
nothing is processed and everything is
done by hand while real humans actually
put it into the jar and then we have a
decoder metal detection and labeling
here at the end
what's the production yield
so we'll do twenty to twenty-five
thousand units a day out of this
facility with started with just one
fridge in a food court has now expanded
to over 400 machines in six different
states first I had the idea for farmer's
fridge and people would say well no one
wants to ever buy food from a vending
machine yeah I would imagine people's
first reaction I said well you know I
don't think you're right I have enough
money in my savings account and on my
credit cards the set up of any machine
and prove you guys wrong and he doesn't
plan to stop until he does how far do
you see the business model going I think
the business goes until everybody's
eating food from vending machines and
feeling like that's a great convenient
option and so really what we've always
said is we're not gonna stop until a
salad is as accessible as a candy bar we
shot this story before the pandemic hit
but currently farmers fridge is serving
at least 30,000 meals each week across
more than a hundred forty health care
facilities during this crisis the
company is taking a 25% of off the price
off all frontline locations and those
prices were originally between 6 and 12
dollars good for them not sure we want
all our food coming from vending
machines Michelle but I have had those
and those salads are very very very good
why not nice